dan crenshaw gets a heated clash with
right-wing comedian about war
what uh so is there anybody here who has
any experience or something like this
maybe someone could shine a light on
what's this all about with dan crenshaw
well actually you know you're not
pulling up this clip but marjorie taylor
green my queen she just got confronted
by some uh you know anti-second
amendment protesters
yeah i know when i was coaching her you
can actually pull it up on her twitter i
think she retweeted it but but i was
basically saying so we're about to show
this crenshaw uh you know interaction
but i had just seen i just saw i don't
even know the proper verbiage but i you
you probably know ryan but i had just
interacted with eric swalwell and eric
swalwell when i said hey fang fang i
heard she gave you insertion and i heard
you guys had an affair he kept his head
down and didn't engage with the troll
which is that's what you should do tim
you don't want to get in the mud with
primetime 99 but dan crenshaw has the
thinnest skin he just has to get in the
mud with a pig like me so watch this i
mean
you just can't you couldn't have hoped
of me it's almost low-hanging fruit at
this point i don't even want to go after
chris anymore i almost feel i'm a little
empathetic to him not sympathetic but
like i kind of feel his pain he just
sucks everybody knows he sucks what
happened to that guy you know well i
mean he voted to kick people out of the
you know army reserves national guard
for not being inoculated he gets angry
at little girls calling him out yeah you
know disagree with his political
opinions when he first started people
were like okay you know i kind of like
this guy what's going on then he kind of
just went off well and the rumor is at
the latest trump event uh the trump
rally he waited to get a photo op and
trump didn't want to photo off with him
so it's just he's a globalist he cares
more about the border between ukraine
and russia and we'll watch this
and that's what i'm saying is and i want
to make this point clear before this
video plays he's trying to go after me
with this narrative that i'm
anti-veterans first of all i care about
our veterans i care about every single
serviceman that has ever had to put on
the uniform that person within the
uniform i care about and i support
wholeheartedly but some of the actions
that the uniform takes the people in
charge i think that we're fighting wars
in the middle east for weapons of mass
destruction that did not exist we have
things called the baccabazi boys where
there are actual rich afghanistan men
all over raping young little kids over
and over and our our our army official
uh narrative was oh they're out they're
our allies so let's not get and they
punished the people who whistleblowed on
that situation the soldiers that said
hey this is crazy they should stop
immediately they talked to the media
they got punished i think there's no
more just reason to start a war and i'm
as anti-war as it gets but if you told
me there's a country of just all
pedophiles attacking children then i'd
say hey and i'm as anti-war against i
say hey maybe we go get involved with
that but the idea that you know this war
was just or that these people were sent
over to the middle east with a clear
objective nobody can prove that you can
just see it but i just want to make this
last point if you look at our withdrawal
from afghanistan with people hanging
from the wheel well of airplanes you
look at them just you know ruining 80
billion dollars of military equipment
just like running over the guns with the
tank they didn't care about in the first
place if they showed that sort of lack
of care on top of drone striking and
murdering about four children that same
week so if that shows you that is the
type of care and procedures and
protocols that they took that took place
in the middle east
it was not justified in anything that
was an aid worker that they said was
isis excel or something
i want to point this out um dan crenshaw
basically said you were shaming a group
of veterans and it's and it seems like
just the the
anybody who watched the video
can conclude that you were talking
specifically about warhawks warmongers
people voting for
needless wars and then his only response
was to be like you hate veterans and
it's just like dude
you like
that's that's the problem i have with
so much of the establishment there's no
engagement they know that if they
actually engage on the issues they lose
on the issues so they just say things
like you're racist you're sexist you
hate veterans etc well just look at the
vietnam war i mean that was unjust i
don't know the last war that we had that
was even justifying i guess world war ii
people will say but my point being is
there's no justifiable reason in my
opinion i know there's other people say
oh we have to start a war i think you're
kind of you know there's a reason to
have war but for me just to kill people
when we have that that thing that makes
us different from animals you know we
should be able to come to some sort of
agreement we don't have to murder
everybody but these people do not care
like dan crenshaw all he cares about is
a military-industrial complex he cares
about halliburton he cares about
raytheon because they're going to donate
money to his political action committee
that is going to keep him in office so
once you are bought and sold by these
corporations you don't care about the
thousands uh hundreds of thousands of
young men that are getting sent to fight
wars for bankers or for imaginary lines
in the sand that don't benefit the
american people if you want to do
something with their troops put them on
the southern border and start helping
you know the people that are are facing
drug and sex trafficking issues every
day why is it that the uh the guy who
described himself before the show as an
idiot and and a comedian is making
better points about politics than dan
crenshaw could when asked about it it's
because i was dropped on my head as a
baby that's why i'm autistically smart
i'm like rain man
i can see the rain man a little bit no
no but and i think everybody feels
pretty similar to that the war in the
middle east was not justified and so for
him trying to be like oh well you're
anti-veteran i'm not i want to do more
to help our veterans our veterans are
treated absolutely terrible there's a
huge suicide rate that you know very
rarely gets very much attention and i
think it's similar to the opioid
epidemic that we're going through the
veterans they don't care about and the
people that die phenomenal overdoses
they don't care about yeah and now the
us army is telling them to go on snap
benefits and food stamps literally to
deal with inflation yeah you can pull up
the store you're right no activities
look up active services
us army snap benefits and the story will
pull up it's a crazy story that
absolutely should make people reconsider
and they wonder why recruitment numbers
are so low well first of all there's so
much propaganda in bull crap but look at
this story tim and we're hiring 87 000
irs agents to go after people that are
making under 400k to get around about 20
billion dollars
you cannot convince me
that we have a country
capable of survival when our army is
being told to go on food stamps
like
that's that's just it that's just it
when when when the government itself
can't pay its own
military and suggests food stamps
ah we're done
like this is just one sign but it's a
big sign there's a big it's a big red
flag and it's got a sickle and a hammer
on it
yeah well i mean idiocracy i know we
always talk about that as a fictional
movie but it's it's pretty real once the
more the federal government gets
involved in something the more they
screw it up so i mean you know and it's
it's history right it's rome i mean this
is rome rome did not take care of their
army they ended up having to hire
mercenaries to carry out their
never-ending wars that they wanted to
keep on going and they treated their own
soldiers so bad they couldn't even staff
it so they had to go and hire
mercenaries but this is it's terrible
yeah yeah but at least uh free
transgender surgery to any soldier that
wants to transition well there's that so
look
the army is getting woke the navy's
getting woke people are retiring
resigning recruitment's
way way down and vax mandates and vax
mandates and now food stamps and they're
like why don't people want to join the
army bro when that commercial came out
where the girl was like i have two moms
i was just sitting here being like and
what does that have to do with being in
the army yeah yeah but this is the
biggest scam tim is how they get people
to join the army for the gi bill and
there's just such a funny meme but it's
so dark and it's like a guy you know his
first day like in boot camps like i
joined the army for free college and
then the next picture it's a guy like
you know with a gun you know in the full
military outfit about to shoot like an
afghanistan guy he's like please don't
shoot me and the guy holding the gun the
military goes like i need free college
so i'm saying that you know they
basically tricked people into getting
free college into becoming literal
warmongers for banks so i i think i
don't like the i guess i don't like the
carrot that they use because they should
make school more accessible we should
take that meme where it's like a guy and
he's in he's in like the army and he's
like
shivering and like you know the cold or
he's in like a desert sweating and then
there's like people shooting at him and
then he's like just remember the eyes
keep your eyes on the prize after all of
the second free college and then the
next one is something like you know fat
dude eating doritos being like bite and
just forgave my my students yeah exactly
yeah and i don't even fault the people
for taking the ten thousand dollars our
government is so dumb uh you know
because that's what everybody says oh
well you took out a ppp loan first of
all our government is is so mismanaged
and i think it's a one percent of the
population has 99 percent of the wealth
so if the government will help you out
50 i think it's is that whatever it is
they got most of it they're hoarding
everything so if the government wants to
give you a break i say take it it's not
going to be fair we have an unfair
system so just try not to make it divide
us and hate each other over it too much
i think you know i was thinking about
the student loan forgiveness thing and i
was like why is it going to matter when
the system collapses
freddie mac there you go i don't think
the agents are going to come to your
house after the apocalypse happens
they're going to be like you owe his
money from that degree well and feel
like okay dude but tim and fight club i
think the end of it is they they uh like
you know tyler durden has the secret
group but they wanted to blow up all the
credit card companies and get rid of the
credit card debt sure is similar to that
right right wipe out all the files
because then everyone goes back to zero
yeah and then and but but that's not
actually a good thing no you know so
like the problem is they're there we do
have a problem with ever like massive
debt but debt between people isn't
always a bad thing like that means
people owe each other and they're going
to work for each other and labor is
going to persist yeah but we're going to
make this last point about keep bogetti
but when they took us off a gold system
now me owing the government a hundred
thousand dollars means the government's
worth a hundred thousand dollars so it
doesn't make sense nothing backs our
whole financial system it literally is
redundant no uh
we have guns
i don't know i don't know i mean we tell
people around the world you use our
money or else yeah that's true because
he tried to take uh he tried to turn
libya on the african dinar and uh and
hillary clinton we came we saw he
died you know and yup to your point
about the student loan issue
the more the government subsidizes
higher ed the more we don't get to have
the real discussion and have the market
pressures about what is a college degree
worth we are getting further and further
away from making them
face
that question because the reality is i
don't know
it depends on it depends on what type of
degree it is it depends on the market
value of the degree
and frankly that needs to be a national
discussion i mean do we need higher ed
for all of these different degree
pathways can we not start certifying
this and guess what start opening this
up for more americans where you can
actually go get these type of jobs by
showing that you're competent and have
the ability to be trained to do this
when i talk to folks you know in the
business community they even talk about
that as well hey i'd rather have a young
person let them come in here let's let
them learn let me train and let me work
with them rather than get them four or
five years down the road six figures in
debt with a degree that frankly i don't
know the degree equates to helping out
in our job hey if you're good at what
you do and you learn and you work well
with others or you've got good ideas get
in here and let's go thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there